Marie-France nous amène là où elle garde
précieusement des souvenirs de son fils
il fallait
parti combattre en Ukraine quelques
semaines seulement après le début de
l'invasion russe il n'est jamais revenu
c'est tout simple il n'était pourtant
pas un militaire et mets Antoine
roi-serouat 31 ans avait étudié en
philosophie et travaillait dans une
entreprise de Montréal mais il ne
supportait pas les images de la guerre
je pense que il est resté un petit peu
avec ce sens là de
c'est peut-être le petit garçon qui
aurait voulu
peut-être voulu qu'il y ait plus de gens
autour pour le protéger quand l'Ukraine
appelle à l'aide Émile quitte son emploi
et sous loue son appartement au
centre-ville alors que toute la famille
le décourage de partir
qui
pouvait le convaincre qui pouvait le
faire changer d'idée
et James un Américain font partie des
volontaires
une fois arrivé il se lit d'amitié avec
un autre Américain que l'on surnomme et
Jay
il est toujours en Ukraine l'été dernier
raconte-t-il ils étaient vraiment dans
l'œil de la tempête
lui était au front le 18 juillet dans le
don-basse près de la ville de cyves
Quentin de leurs camarade a été atteint
par des éclats d'obus Émile a tenté de
lui porter secours
américain à l'arrière-plan sur cette
photo de même quai de Var d'un suédois
sont morts sur le coup
après avoir battu en retraite et Jay est
revenu chercher le corps de son ami
ils ont tenu une cérémonie en son
honneur
avait encore beaucoup de belles choses à
vivre
bouleversée Marie-France se console en
se disant que son fils était heureux qui
se sentait utile
je pense qu'il faut
il faut souligner le courage de
personnes comme mon fils qui disait
on peut pas on peut pas accepter ça elle
se console aussi grâce au soutien de la
communauté ukrainienne votre fille
est tombé sur le champ de bataille
comme héros je t'aime Émile
repose en paix certains sont même venus
lui demander pardon
vous avez pas demandé pardon vous
souffrez déjà tellement un peuple à qui
elle et son fils sont liés pour toujours
avec moi ici Sébastien Desrosiers
Radio-Canada Montréal